une arrivée qui ne passe pas inaperçu
depuis samedi
tous les yeux sont rivés sur nicolas
stoehr john et le bras de fer qu'elle
s'apprête à entamer avec boris johnson
les indépendantistes ont raflé 64 sièges
sur 129 du parlement écossais se place
ont donc un siège près de la majorité
absolue
une écrasante victoire pour le snp
positionnant londres dans l'embarras je
soutiens l'indépendance le gouvernement
britanniques s'opposent à l'indépendance
c'est légitime mais les seules personnes
qui ont le droit de décider de cette
question sont les écossais et le moyen
de le faire est un référendum
les statistiques de cette campagne
électorale bat des records pour le snp
de sorte que la question qui se pose au
gouvernement britannique est simple et
ne devrait pas prêter à controverse
acceptent-ils la démocratie ou non et
j'espère que quel que soit la position
qu'ils adoptent à ce stade ils
accepteront la démocratie le référendum
comme principes démocratiques
une stratégie similaire adoptée par
boris johnson lui même lors de sa
compagne pour la sortie de l'union
européenne nicolas stores jeune
militante pro indépendance depuis 35 ans
n'a pas digéré la victoire du non en
2014 à 55%
un premier référendum organisé avant le
break site et sans le soutien des verts
qui ont fait samedi une percée
historique aux élections est pour le
moment le gouvernement britannique se
montre réticent principal argument la
priorité est de sortir de la crise
sanitaire
si nous nous laissons entraîner dans une
conversation sur les référendums les
constitutions et tout le reste
alors nous détournons l'attention des
questions qui sont les plus importantes
pour les gens en écosse et à travers le
royaume uni et comme je les dis je ne
peux pas croire que les gens qui sont
inquiets pour leur emploi
inquiet de la prolongation des congés
inquiet de ce qui arrive à l'éducation
de leurs enfants
je ne peux pas croire qu'il pense que la
réponse à toutes ces choses et en débats
prolongés sur la constitution
boris johnson a invité nicolas sturgess
à travailler ensemble elle a convié à
une réunion avec les autres chefs de
gouvernements locaux
mais si londres sentait à s'opposer à la
demande à nouveau référendum
la première ministre écossaise pourrait
alors saisir la cour suprême britannique